What are vitamins that help Lyme disease?
Again, there's really three stages of Lyme disease. So if a person is in stage one,
stage one is defined by
the fact that you person just got the tick bite. So you're just infected with an acute bacterial infection,
Borrelia, Nurgidorphy, is the bacteria in Lyme disease. But I know there's multiple different
bacteria and viruses that are co-infections that go along with Lyme disease. But so when I say
Lyme disease, I'm talking about Nurgidorphy and the multiple co-infections. So a person just gets Lyme
disease, you cannot kill the viral component, you know, except by through your own immune system
function. But you can kill the bacterial component when it's still in the blood,
still in the tissues, but it has not yet traversed to go inside of a cell. So if it's still in the
tissues, still in the blood, you can kill the bacterial component of Lyme disease with an antibiotic.
So I always recommend that if you have acute Lyme disease, which I call stage one Lyme disease,
you use an antibiotic. You use antibiotic therapy to kill it. That's going to be your best bet.
Problem is, is that many times you won't catch it, but it's still in phase one. Again, phase one is
defined as the bacteria has not yet gone intracellular inside of a cell.
Well, you might just have the symptoms of Lyme disease, which are like flu-like symptoms.
And you go to a doctor and you say, hey, I was outside, I got bitten by a tick, maybe you did,
maybe you didn't find the tick on your body member. It's a deer tick, not just a regular wood tick.
And you maybe had a bullseye rash, maybe didn't have a bullseye rash. Regardless, you may end up with
a doctor who won't prescribe an antibiotic without getting a Lyme blood test, which I think is
is foolishness. Find a different doctor that will prescribe based upon symptoms,
based upon signs other than labs. The reason is, is if you get the blood test and you wait a week to
get that blood test back, that they have already progressed into phase two, meaning that the bacteria
has gone intracellular. So, as long as you have one bacteria that goes inside the cell,
you have the chance of not being able to kill it all through using an antibiotic.
If you catch it truly in phase one, and you use an antibiotic nine times out of 10,
you're going to be able to knock it out of your system, and you're not going to be worried about
taking the vitamins for it because you have killed it with an antibiotic. Now, taking other vitamins
to nutrition that will stimulate and immune response at that point are beneficial because
that's the viral component. So, we have a product called acute LX, which I created specifically for
that acute phase line, but that isn't the substitute for an antibiotic. So, I still recommend that you
get an antibiotic in that situation. If you go to a doctor that says we need to get a blood test
before I could give it an antibiotic, go to another doctor immediately, try to get an antibiotic for
that situation because you may miss it. Once it goes into phase two, once the bacteria goes intracellularly,
then it can start reproducing inside the cell and create a chronic disorder. So, once it's in a
chronic disorder, then it's more difficult to kill it with an antibiotic because antibiotics don't
go intracellularly and it won't kill the bacteria when it's inside the cell. So, it will replicate
inside the cell and then come outside the cell and then go into the tissue. That's what antibiotics
can work. That's where long-term antibiotic use can be beneficial for those with chronic
Lyme disease, phase two Lyme disease. The problem is long-term antibiotic use reads having
the rest of the body in your gut system, etc. Then there's also a phase three Lyme disease where your
body has now made antibodies against cell tissue because this bacteria is continuing to go inside and
outside the cell. Your immune system is trying to kill it and then your B cell response of your
immune system can then create antibodies against cell tissue. So, you now have antibodies against
cell tissue. You now have an autoimmune disease. Chronic infections like Lyme, chronic infections
like Epstein Bar and things like that are known to be a major trigger to stimulate an autoimmune
disease to disease. To something that a trigger to an autoimmune disease is something that the
immune system is unable to kill for various reasons and that it creates antibodies to self-tissue
where it's found that bacteria and now you have antibodies to your own cells. That's the definition
of an autoimmune disease. Once you have autoimmune disease, phase three Lyme or an autoimmune disease
of any kind whatsoever. So, you have antibodies to self-tissue and you have no idea what caused it.
That your whole other game and you absolutely need to get that chronic disease in autoimmune
course because you should not be taking any immune stimulants long-term immune stimulants if you
have self-antibodies. That goes for if I have Hashimoto's, well that's antibodies to the thyroid
gland. You should not be taking long-term immune stimulants. You should all use immune stimulants
to acute phase reactions. So, a lot to do there. I spoke quickly but that's all in our Lyme course
and our autoimmune course.